[Musique]
nous sommes le 28 février 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités émission dédiée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département invité aujourd'hui un char
locked marchandises devrait être la
candidate issu de la primaire ouverte
sur internet est désignée par la
primaire point org ces comités locaux
s'organisent
bertrand hugon est en charge de
l'antenne de saint quentin en yvelines
et d'invités de cette édition
thomas bach ou kramer français
originaires du chesnay et licencié au
cercle nautique de versailles mais
n'allez médaillé de bronze à rio ils se
préparent pour deux nouvelles échéances
rencontre avec le champion yvelinois
bertrand bonsoir bonsoir vous est le
cofondateur du comité de soutien de
charlotte marchandises cette candidate à
l'élection présidentielle désigné par un
vote citoyen sur internet sur le site la
primaire point hors combat déjà revenir
sur cette désignation qui est un peu
inédite
comment s'est organisé le scrutin la
désignation s'est faite en ligne fin
décembre
il ya eu deux tours c'était une élection
classique en quelque sorte pas classique
du tout en fait parce que si ça avait
été classique je pense pas que j'y
adhérais nous qui sommes dans le comité
de soutien à charlotte marchandises sur
saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes de simples citoyens qui
souhaitons nous engager donc en
politique nous trouvons que c'est normal
de s'occuper des affaires de la cité et
de notre pays cependant nous deux
nous retrouvons pas dans les partis
politiques traditionnels
nous voyons d'ailleurs ces partis
politiques plus comme des obstacles à la
démocratie comme des outils pour la
faire vivre
justement justement dans donc la
primaire - org
nous avons trouvé nous le pensons donc
un outil qui permet de désigner des
représentants des citoyens des
représentants donc du peuple
d'une manière plus acceptable d'un point
de vue démocratique mais qui a initié ce
mouvement parce qu'il a bien fallu
s'organiser il faut malgré tout une
structure c'est un avocat un ingénieur
informatique qui sont derrière tout ça
en fait oui exactement est cependant
dans de simples citoyens derrière donc
l'association démocrate est qu est ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que la processus
de le processus de désignation donc du
candidat donc vainqueur de la primaire
s'est étalée surtout 2016
on a eu d'abord en fait n'importe qui
pouvait donc ça inscrire y avait pas
besoin d'avoir de soutien de maires des
élus de professionnels de la politique
il suffisait donc environ où je crois y
avait 500 candidats à plusieurs
centaines de candidats dont juste en
fait une vingtaine de femmes d'obtenir
500 soutien de citoyens par internet
on a eu mi-2016 donc seize candidats qui
ont atteint ce quorum de 500 parrainages
et citoyens voilà
ensuite on a eu un premier tour donc
d'élections mais à un premier tour
d'élection fapa dans l'est pas comme
dans les élections classiques ou en fait
où on voit on n'arrive qu'à voir que
deux trois candidats et les autres en
fait donc on les voit pas donc eu du
tout en fait il y avait certes 16
candidats finalistes mais chaque votant
recevait une sélection aléatoire de cinq
candidats avec des liens vers leurs
priorités et leurs programmes ce qui
fait que un internaute
même s'il ne connaissait pas a priori
donc c'est ses candidats en en recevant
juste 5 on pouvait se faire une idée
donc assez claire de composition de ces
points de programme parce qu'il y avait
des programmes et des propositions qui
ont été qui ont été émises et d'ailleurs
on va y venir aussi aux propositions et
charlotte marchandises qui a été
désignée c'est elle qui a remporté le
second tour avec un peu plus de 50% des
trente-deux mille voix qui se sont
exprimées
une comparaison rapide avec la première
de la gauche et de la droite on est loin
en dessous non moi c'est un peu plus que
la primaire écologiste
en tout cas charles autres marchandises
qui s'est imposé elle défend quelle idée
aujourd'hui
et quelles sont les idées que vous vous
défendez à travers d'accords juste mais
je reviens sur le scrutin parce qu'il ya
des choses qui sont pas comparables avec
ce qu'on voit dans la vie politique donc
actuelle c'est à dire que il recevait
certes cinq ministres de cinq candidats
mais on votait pas pour l'un à
l'exclusion de tous les autres c'est à
dire que le citoyen pouvait donner une
appréciation à chacun des cinq candidats
allant de pas satisfaisant jusqu'à très
satisfaisant et charlotte marchandises
et la candidate qui même donc à l'issue
du second vote sur la part qu'on tourne
donc à voter pour les cinq finalistes de
la finale elle a obtenu plus de 50%
d'options de mention on va dire très
favorable alors quels sont les points de
programme très favorable justement
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'elle défend
aujourd'hui ce qu'elle défende est en
tout cas il ya la primaire c'est à dire
ce qu'il ya écrit donc sur le site donc
on peut pas donc revenir donc dessus
c'est trois priorités est importante
la première donc c'est la démocratie
s'est refondée se donner deux ans pour
refonder donc les institutions en ayant
toujours en tête la règle l'une des
règles principales de la démocratie et
tant que ce n'est pas aux hommes de
pouvoir décrire les règles de pouvoir
donc il est bien entendu que les
politiciens professionnels ne sont pas
légitimes pour proposer des changements
constitutionnels
il y avait il y a dans les dents la
priorité donc dans les engagements de
charlotte donc marchandises
[Musique]
une priorité forte sur le lien social
elle le propose un revenu de base
universel car ça c'est une proposition
qu'on retrouve aussi séché des candidats
le classique issu du système je pense à
benoît groulx par exemple sur ce revenu
universel qu'est ce qui fait la
différence entre les deux qu'est ce qui
pour vous aussi en tant que citoyens et
électeurs ont fait la différence
bah c est que benoît hamon a dit comment
il allait financer son revenu donc
universelle il a dit clairement que sa
lettre dont parle en dépend donc du pays
et nous pensons que de mettre le pays
les citoyens à genoux devant les banques
c'est pas un avenir souhaitable pour
nous tous pour être candidat il faut
néanmoins des parrainages les
parrainages d'élus est ce que c'est
votre marchandise va les obtenir
c'est le travail que vous avez mené bien
sûr bien sûr oui bah donc concrètement
donc nous allons voir les élus de
terrain j'ai rendez vous avec à la
mairie de guyancourt ma commune ce
vendredi sur la france pour l'instant à
l'heure actuelle charlotte marchandises
à entre 300 et 350 promesses de
parrainages
sachant que bon ce sont pour l'instant
donc des promesses il faudra consulter
le site du conseil constitutionnel pas
plus tard que demain pour avoir déjà
donc un premier état des parrainages que
le conseil a effectivement reçu plaisir
a jusqu'au 17 mars un pour les
différents élus pour se prononcer et
apporter leur soutien ou non à certains
candidats pour qu'ensuite ils puissent
se présenter c'est le jeu démocratique
jusqu'à présent ce sont les règles en
tout cas comment vous allez organiser
votre comité parce que vous êtes co
fondateur de ce comité sur ses comptes
en yvelines ce sera ma dernière question
vous allez organiser quoi des meetings
et faire du porte-à-porte comment va se
passer la campagne pour vous quand est
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que pour
l'instant là maintenant tout de suite
la priorité ce sont les parrainages et
les parrainages ce sont donc les élus
les maires éventuellement d'autres types
d'élus des députés dont européen des
élus donc de conseil donc régionaux mais
n'ont pour l'instant c'est clair la
campagne c'est allé voir les maires pour
qu'ils
donnent leurs parrainages maintenant au
niveau organisation n'y a pas
d'organisation a lorsqu'on est d'accord
sur le sur ce qui est à faire sur
l'objectif on n'a pas vraiment à
s'organiser
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que et on verra
si vous avez réussi à retenir c'est
différent parrainage et vous reviendrez
à cette occasion arrive au bout de cet
entretien
et merci bertrand hugo confondateur du
comité de soutien de charlotte
marchandises candidates de cette
primaire candidate issue de cette
primaire organisée sur le site internet
primaire point org merci à vous le sport
pour poursuivre cette édition nous
parlons à d'aviron à présent dans ce set
8 invité la fédération internationale a
décidé de supprimer le début février le
4 x 100 barreur poids léger des jeux
olympiques à un coup dur pour le
versailles et thomas baruch médaillé de
bronze au dernier giro dans cette
catégorie et qui compte quatre sportifs
à bord du bateau un michael et demi
d'euros est allé le rencontrer devant le
cercle nautique de versailles a là où
ils et elles licenciés c'est au grand
canal du château alors je suis avec
thomas baruch médaille de bronze aux
derniers jeux olympiques de rio l'été
dernier alors thomas barrau qui n'est
pas forcément de très bonne humeur
aujourd'hui ce matin puisque sa
catégorie le quatre sans barreur poids
léger vient tout simplement de
disparaître du programme olympique une
décision de la fédération internationale
alors thomas baruch vous dans quel
sentiment vous avez suite à cette
annonce je suis pas surpris 1 c des
discussions qui ont lieu depuis deux ans
maintenant
je me suis un petit peu investi pour
essayer de défendre ma catégorie de
faire valoir quelques arguments on avait
bien senti que
ça avait du mal à convaincre et qu'il y
avait beaucoup de poids en face de la
part de la fédération internationale et
d'autres institutions qui disait que
j'étais assez peu positif sur l'issue du
vote
déçu forcément et puis surtout
maintenant
il va falloir se lancer dans un nouveau
défi puisque avec mon coéquipier timoko
l'orne a décidé de changer de catégorie
et de passer en pointe toutes catégories
justement donc on va se retrouver contre
des adversaires qui auront quelques
centimètres et quelques pilotes puisque
nous et est ce que c'est une décision
logique peut-être qu'il y avait moi
licenciés peut-être dans cette catégorie
où peut-être bonnes pratiques en de mon
point de vue non elle n'est absolument
pas logique puisque l'avion poids légers
a été développé pour ouvrir notre sport
justement à des nations qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de le pratiquer je pense
notamment de toutes les nations
asiatiques qui ont plutôt des physiques
qui se rapprochent naturellement de
l'aviron poids léger c'était l'une des
courses passé la course dans laquelle
l'écart entre le premier et le 6e et le
plus faible sur tout les olympiades qui
sont courues donc ça donne des courses
assez spectaculaire qui sont après qui a
été apprécié tous les spectateurs donc
clairement je ne vois pas les arguments
logiques qui justifiait décision est ce
qu on a consulté les sportifs pour avant
de prendre cette décision n'a pas
consulté des sportifs directement après
chacun était libre de s'exprimer donc
ceux qui ont voulu le faire l'ont pu le
faire et quelles conséquences à avoir
sur votre saison à tobrouk la première
c'est qu'on va devoir faire les
sélections pour l'équipe nationale en
toutes catégories
sachant que c'est dans moins de deux
mois maintenant un mois et demi donc on
n'a pas le temps de vraiment développer
des capacités physiques supplémentaires
donc on va aller faire ses sélections on
va dire en tant que poids légers en
ayant une contrainte de moins
qu'ils essaient de la pause et deux
heures avant la course vous allez
abandonner complètement le quatre sans
barreur alors le 400 bars non parce que
je pense que le bateau dans lequel on a
le plus de chances de bien figurer au
niveau international c'est justement de
400 bars ou éventuellement le deux sans
barreur ça ça reste à voir ça va être
aussi en fonction des objectifs de la
fédération
est-ce que vous allez devoir revoir
votre préparation vue des prochains jeux
olympiques je pense que c'est l'un de
vos objectifs
alors c'est sûr que l'objectif c'est
clairement les prochains jeux de tokyo
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on a fait le
choix de de passer tout de suite en
toutes catégories et ne pas attendre six
à huit mois supplémentaire d'aller
jusqu'aux championnats du monde en poids
légers pour ensuite faire le changement
sur la sur la façon de s'entraîner n'ont
pas vraiment après falloir réfléchir à
quelles sont les forces et les
faiblesses qu'on peut avoir et voir
comment comment progresser tout
simplement vous allez devoir prendre
peut-être du poids vous allez tomber
dans une catégorie avec des athlètes qui
feront peut-être à mettre 90 1 mètre 95
des dizaines de kilos de plus que vous
est-ce qu'il va falloir que vous prenez
du poids
thomas baruch c'est par un objectif en
soi
qui l'objectif c'est d'être plus
performant c'est d'aller plus vite en
bateau éventuellement d'améliorer les
performances physiques pour le faire
mais vraiment on est plus dans un
rapport poids puissance qu'il faudra
optimiser plutôt que de simplement
prendre du poids parce qu'on avions le
poids c'est un frein plus le bateau est
lourd plus il est freiné par l'eau donc
est plus difficile à mettre en mouvement
donc ça à part un intérêt direct de
prendre du poids vous serez peut-être
plus technique peut-être par rapport à
des gabarits de avec 95 ce qui est sûr
c'est que je pourrais pas réalisé avec
uniquement sur la puissance donc
clairement il va falloir utiliser la
technique qui est le plus efficace
possible
donc voilà faut continuer à travailler
parce qu'on peut toujours progresser
c'est ça qui est magnifique en avion et
puis falloir arriver à peut-être
développer plus de puissance enfin
adapter la technique pour développer
plus de puissance en bateau et ça ça va
être l'enjeu tic dont j'ai donné votre
objectif sera de ramener une médaille
maintenant au prochain giro et même s'il
ya eu ce changement de catégorie ça ne
change pas vos plans ramener une
médaille
encore une fois oui là on est encore
assez loin même très loin des prochains
jeux de tokyo donc c'est en 2020 en a le
temps de voir
on a le temps de travailler sur tout ce
qui est clair c'est qu'on continue pour
faire au moins aussi bien que à rio donc
donc d'aller chercher une médaille
maintenant voilà ça va pas être évident
il faudra aussi voir quelle est la
concurrence et quelles sont les forces
en présence et puis ensuite on pourra se
positionner plus clairement ses
décisions ne restera pas à tobrouk
en tout cas non j'ai quand il je compte
bien continuer encore quelques années
merci beaucoup et au maroc merci thomas
bach ok merci à michael et demi d'euros
pour cette interview c'est la fin du set
8 les invitaient rendez vous demain aux
horaires habituels et dès à présent sur
notre site internet
[Musique]